[Applauso]
[Musica]
[Risate]
contro già oggi nove semi sky broomball
frusta portato prigione angelo contro
diavolo ecco qua vedete qua abbiamo la
scelta se scegliere di essere un anno o
un diavolo avevamo già scelto io voglio
essere un angelo come vedete oggi sono
tutte bianche invece evitare soprattutto
non siamo perciò click l'angelo e il
diavolo
questa è la più bella di ali le mie
colleghi vitale
per scoprire se voi siete angelo o
diavolo lasciate un mi piace qui sotto
se il vostro mi piace finisce con una
cifra pari
siete un angelo se invece il vostro vi
piace finisce con una cifra di vari siti
di abbiamo più vitale chi vincerà questa
azione l'uomo notivà angeli o team
diavoli prima di iniziare vi ricordo che
il mio libro storie paurose ora
disponibile per il preordine sul toro
per i primissimi che preordinano
riceveranno scrivere libri una cartolina
autografata da me e david orr quindi
preordinate non so mica se non avete
visto il video presentazione in cui vi
spiego di cosa parla tutte le cose che
ci sono all'interno perché c'è anche una
challenge all'interno con dei luoghi e
super divertente andate poi a vederlo
dopo questo video vi do sul in qua qua
qua o la casellina finale ma sbaglio tu
mi hai già superato la mente parlare
fra de paris questo nel karma
ovviamente vincerà chi riesce a
completare per primo lembo c'è chi
prende per primo il badge quindi se voi
siete team diavoli farete il tipo per
vitale
[Applauso]
[Musica]
per i bar e papà ma insomma è troppo
difficile saltare su corteo reale
viaggio e lì intanto dove hai visto
quanti sono tutte le ali da ho visto
niente io io ho davanti in pasta
mordano pure io ho fatto
una striscia celeste su cui non bisogna
parlare ma è tipo volta difficile da
vedere ecco vitale
non ci credo mi ha spinto spinto in via
dicendo ma io sto andando per i fatti
miei ma questi sono cubetti di ghiaccio
ho capito agli in alcuni cubetti si può
saltare in altri no
guardando il volo vitale imbaba
giovanotto esteticamente bellissimo
questo schifo perché rosa celeste modo
favori alle ali e bellissima ti vuoi
sbrigare vitale diavolo è lassù fate
alisei sono otto parlai e sono ancora 7
senza aspettati io sono al
90 io sto andando velocissimi subissimo
wow è bellissima queste schifo room o
così sono tutti gli angioletti e troppo
carino
mi dispiace non c'è niente ottima
diavolo perché si aspetta aspetta vedrai
perché stai facendo qua
sono al fido di te adesso che pure belle
queste cascate
no non ci credo cosa sei tu che sei
intruppata sicuramente la macchina di
barchi e aspi no io non posso spingersi
perché io sono l'angelo
mi to il diavolo presso mandiamo il
raggiungiamo vitale diavolo quasi sera
adattare la giusta e tra queste proprio
non so
se firmi tu no roma 3 giu saro morti ha
fatto a cadere perché tirolo troppo lo
ha inventato quella trappola sì l'ho
messo io ecco vitale è allontanati
diavolo non mi fido di te allora qua
come sembra tipo un materassino che non
si può passare quando dobbiamo saltare
poi i lati ed elmas ha fatto perdere
l'equilibrio a 30 allontanati to diavola
è o non servitore si avvicina mi fa
cadere no basta
ottenere la distanza da vitale che mi fa
gli scherzi belle resterà lì da angelo
che belle come sempre queste la dal
bisogno sfracellato adem pari no mi sta
sprigionando esposto che cos'è dai di
quadri saltare per risultare di qua
no
non mi devo fidare di quello che dice
vitale diavolo no ma anche io mi sto
sfracellando cose in pari non so cosa
sia successo ma sono riuscita a saltare
sulla terzi adesso quando guarda
forse in tutto gattine ali da angelo per
questo sto volando chacha imago qua ciao
io vado avanti dalla strage la tara sei
riuscito a passare è certo brava
il diavolo è solo già avanti prova a
prendermi ehi guarda laggiù iniziano
forte diavolo questa natura la parte
angelo per questo era tutta bianca rosa
celeste invece legge c'e una parte
diavolo giornata terra pensa che io poi
mi sono già sfracellato mille volte è
infatti le loro piano piano
come si fa a cristo scodellato cern ha
finalmente superato vitale fatto io
continuo a sfracellarsi sempre qui ecco
vitale diavolo laggiù vediamo che il
continuo a sfracellarsi non circolino
domani sempre miss fratello non è
bello non appaltate in un tunnel di
aureo lei dove sta scappando via
o no vitale riuscito a superare quello
james e devo sbrigarmi ebbene si no
beh ti sei strafare ha menzionato premio
20 di pink lo so che cosa mi ha dato una
medaglia da devono vincerlo e belgio
come ho fatto progettarne che strano
questo stage certo luminoso è bellissima
questa partita angelo
arrivare alla parte diavolo e viene a
scappare perché io questo sfracellando
approfittiamo dal fatto che vitagliano
riesce e aspetta uno vetta perché
magari per una cosa strana questo eco
vita e tanto si sfracella ray 10.000
volte su due
capisco cosa bisogna fare per te bisogna
saltare solenne alcuni punti delle
nuvole sì è proprio così
bisogna stare attenti a saltare al
centro delle nuvole non si è fatta più
belle queste casca bombe speriamo che è
vitale rimanga bloccato
la carta mi dice che tim diavoli
indietro non troppo sai dove mancherà di
nuvole ma direi che sono stato più
veloce di te siamo arrivati alla parte
dedicata ai diavoli del bios lei
tornavano qua cambia completamente
l'ambientazione di queste
scriviamo vediamolo con le cornee del
tutto rock 30 questa è una delle scritte
più belle esteticamente si abbiamo mai
fatto e poi è bellissimo il fatto che
puoi scegliere se essere o angelo o
diavolo adesso siamo nella mia vita le
mie troverà superveloce andrò alla fine
del video scrivete se vi è piaciuta più
la parte a gino o la parte diavolo
chissà cosa ci aspetta vediamo se skype
room spero che non ti aspetti qualche
nemico adatto
il pavimento e lava ma perché tesi
sfracellata così mi si è gelato donna
non cercano
e ora dove vado proviamo a portare fatto
anzi credo
quindi è tutta roba portando quasi un
trucco per vedere quale io vado davvero
quella giusta bene allora il trucco del
seguire vitale una piccola e giusto però
no
vendita quale scelto adesso allora è
quella gialla anche attenta qui c'è che
senza no pensavo ci fosse un
bravissimo anche qua guai invece di
essere giorno e notte che cos'è questo è
un vulcano ecco da dove arriva tutta la
lava legge c'è qualcosa di strano ci
sono delle ali rosse giganti dai team
angeli possiamo dare per colpa
per colpa mia non
mi hai lasciato lo spazio su quella
mattonella se c'è un fanta non ci credo
anch'io non mi sono sbagliata non è
possibile
sono caduto come una pera
sono questi gialli
ecco le ali gitanti e ora dove stiano
sono queste cose questo e mattonelle
verdi punto vendita ci credono sempre in
mezzo ai piedi mi dispiace per voi
noi ti immagini siamo in vantaggio all
ice la luna piena o a piccolo spoiler
per voi nel libro storie paurose c'è la
luna piena anzi succede una
trasformazione durante l'anno
forse alcuni di voi riusciranno a capire
che trasformazione effettiva della luna
piena se avete preordinato il libro
scrivetelo nei commenti
abbiamo
fatto sfracellarsi comparto sono spregio
lato perché continuo a sfracellarsi
anch'io
vuol dire che non erano la rotta giusta
forse la strada giusta e questo ei no
c'è qualcosa che non quadra o come
direbbe evitare c'è qualcosa che una
donna abbiamo dovuto fare uno stage
perché il gioco è varcato e non fa
continuare perché il babbo team fatto io
no però sembra che stiamo tipo nel regno
di dracula sembrano tipo pipistrelli
quindi ovvero una capretta de la
mandragola tipo ha quindi bisogna andare
qui su questi treni regionali ma ho
visto che chiedevo anno non sei caduta e
ora c'è nulla billie joe che sta
prendendo fuoco vero ma sono qui
giornale di atterrare la b
e non aiuterà i battiti sta inseguendo
si perde sempre siamo sentiti per merito
e che pirani
quante volte si è sfracellato senarica
per colpa tua che sta in mezzo ai piedi
[Risate]
penso che sia la 148esima volte che mi
sfracello diamo in vantaggio arriva team
angeli in vantaggio non riesco ad andare
avanti neanche poco poco lo vedete
laggiù vitale che cade
da e siccome sono angelo e non diavolo
come te ti aiuta a superare uno stage
wow quasi tipo un tappeto invisibile che
mi trasporta persona
ecco vitale serie si fa superare questo
stage ma che stai facendo una catena so
perché milan dove si muove così piano è
meglio che mi sbrigo ti affettato filtra
anche sulla maledizione qui le regioni
finora un pazzo ma stiamo per
raggiungere la fine delle sky from forse
vinceranno gli angeli
ho capito e trova come sono maturati
lato si capisce di più dove si sta
andando al bisogna saltare 400mila per
dai di farcela diavolo dai team diavoli
potete farcela stai molto attento perché
perché lei net stable sapeva
[Musica]
non devi mai dire stai molto a 200 dai
facciamo il tifo per evitare poverino
ha
funzionato il vostro tifo per bisoli e
adesso adesso se nessuno isolato e
bellissimo queste skype room stiamo
tornando fortuna parte degli angeli vedi
c'è una fune importazioni atene a portà
rossa che come farò dire abbiamo già
detto della morta giusta
forse siamo arrivati alla fine o forse
torneremo nella parte degli angeli se
riusciamo a passare questa tesi sono
fatta e ora tutto ok aspettiamoci
immediato li vediamo capitale quante
volte
cercato tracce e la venta numero secondo
me dovrebbero metterlo tipo un numeretto
il mio conto sarebbe tipo infinito e
l'ultimo
allora io vedo nella portabilità io vado
alla rossa
erano porta sbagliata
tu invece dovesse infinito sono solo se
uno sta andando avanti nel
perseguire la porta rossa porta rossa
c'è scritto calais degli angeli oppure
cava dei demoni e io vado nelle scale
degli angeli o via mail invece sono
andato nelle cave di demoni pistons pro
gela dove guarda ora è tutto diviso a
metà la voce di celeste dall'altro sia
rosso quindi sono tre team angeli
dall'altro sin diavoli machista e
straparlano sempre come vedo io un po
difficile questa parte ma e mezzo
tutto ci sono chi posso scusi
all'articolo
torta rotta e porta no blu allora blu
allora
sarà
già
era quello rosa ei tre java ed è certo
ecco vitale laggiù salviamo scappiamo
scappiamo chiamo salendo notissimo
queste parti sono difficilissime sono
accorto vinsero archivi geraghty
mantenuti i diavoli che belle ci sono
delle ali da angelo
fluorescenti bellissime è riuscito a
passare laggiù c'è una porta con delle
fiamme le ali da diavolo non so cosa ci
aspetta laggiù e il pavimento e la vacua
difficilissimo questo stage non so
dovete far saltare per una volta 86
avanti mi dispiace per te ma io mi
sfracello di me io sono rimasto bloccato
sulle ali così sono delle barchette
d'angelo che carica
perché perché sono un porta cd rivolta
questo ponte con le fiamme dove mi
porterà
mi ha portato nella grotta prima cosa la
prosa del team diavolo tipo una miniera
una grotta bellissimo però
l'ambientazione è bellissima però
dall'altra parte c'è poi la parte degli
angeli ecco team diavoli allora
come fatto il no
vediamo che finalmente che si trova a
superare team angeli
avvocati però nello stesso punto
dove bisogna andare tu qua disegni
essere superate titolo cadiamo
nell'europa
conforti averlo fatto il passaggio
novità verrà comunque javaday si fa una
tranquilla mi sto continuando a sfornare
proprio come se non ci fosse un domani
ciò per arrivare alla porta degli angeli
se mancano solo due ali da friends
che cos'era quel tonfo
manca mai ma dove devo saltare
per mi fa andare
forse la strada sbagliata non credo e lì
la porta no è solo che sei schiappa
son caduto però se la cava il tutto pero
invita leva che poco no non può essere
di diavoli abito
ci sono quasi ci sono quasi ci sono
quasi tutte vittorie dove storici piano
per primo
[Musica]
credo
diavolo
ferro 4 per com è stato chiamato
negati aspettato costati la vita a volte
lasciato bel mi piace vi ricorda di
cliccare un link e descrizione per premi
non ha paura di ricevere la cartolina
autografata da evitare ora vi lasciamo
qua quattro casse lire su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video chat e
su quella che preferite buona visione
ciao